[Music]
welcome back to
the record where we talk about whatever
we want in part what are we talking
about today we're going to talk about
whoa what's that my fingers i'm
hey where are you from oh shooting that
fool's from l.a oh [ __ ]
oh my god i'll go get the [ __ ] out of
here
people out of town are like oh [ __ ] i'm
sorry i'm sorry dad their thugs are kind
of weird
yeah damn it's pride month okay oh [ __ ]
now we're talking about how you tan your
[ __ ] yeah so what did you bring up
uh i forgot what exactly we were talking
about but i
brought up that there are people i saw
an article about like girls like
yeah and speaking wizards who were uh
basically
tanning their nether regions they would
like open their legs to the
other region privates like this yeah
like your private parts
they would like tan their buttholes and
their uh
vaginals yeah they're the nooks and
crannies i guess
they're [ __ ] in their [ __ ] for
immediate vitamin d
consumption actually that's what they
said they said like it just like gets to
your body
it's 20 faster so what's the difference
between that's legit like what they said
but what's the difference between your
[ __ ] and going like this
i guess not maybe your mouth gets dry i
guess your [ __ ] gets dry too
they both get dressed you got to use all
the snail trail dries up yeah you know
um so then she said that and i was like
oh yeah i've done that but when i did it
i did it as a joke because i saw
a picture of a child yo i'll admit it i
have no [ __ ] shame
uh so there's a picture of this chick on
a mountain like on a cliff it was a
[ __ ] epic beautiful picture and she's
just like this so you just kind of see
this angle sorry joe of like her going
like this
and i was like oh god i gotta parody
this so then i
got but this is stupid i obviously never
put it up but i got it now though and
then i did it and i'm like i don't think
i could post this
uh but as i was doing it it feels very
nice does it
like the sun the sun on your puss plus
yeah because it's if you think about it
warm and it's bacon
yeah uh so it's an area that you don't
touch
right so it's highly sensitive yeah for
some of us
do you got tan lines not no more
see not no more because how often does
your dick and balls and
and vagina get exposure to sun never
right so then like now imagine
what the sun feels like on your face
right and then how it feels on your
eyelids
on your lips just don't open your eyes
you don't open your eyes i mean yeah you
probably can't even start it either but
then now imagine it like
you opening up in an area that doesn't
get
like light exposure like definitely
it gets the least amount of light on the
rest of your body right so like it's not
fueling all of the elements and now you
expose it to the sun and it's
very warm and cool when you describe it
it sounds like one of those
like freshly baked costco cookies like
the one that you get as a sample
bro i couldn't have described it better
that's what you're describing it as and
it sounds fantastic you know i'm gonna
try it
because yeah i walk around good yeah i
feel like my dick and balls doesn't need
to get any more time
not it's not about the tan it's about
the vitamin d that you get
just do it for five years recognizable
but we already go naked right the our
equivalent
is to peel our foreskin back and then
expose that to the side
you know what though what if it burns
yeah yeah
you can't show it too much in your
butthole you gotta get your butthole in
it if you
if you expose it too long your your your
private parts are going to get sunburned
i i need to do that because
when i roll it up i have a farmer's tab
right
here
[Laughter]
why do all of our dicks have farmer's
tabs
now you know pull it back it's science
let the sun hit a little bit
science how long can we last though just
do five minutes
we're gonna get sunburned if you do it
like i do in the morning during the blue
light
yes it's that song oh hey where did you
get one of those the reflectors for your
dick
you got like a panda you gotta get a
coke candy
i feel like my balls are too dark though
i know yeah asian dudes balls
balls it's not for the tanning like
that out the window or the warmth but i
don't want to know warm cookie
i don't want to turn it into a raisin
you sound like a [ __ ] i know
don't turn your back on this bro don't
turn your back on yeah we're all in dude
are we doing this together located it
could be like a fun activity like team
bonding
yeah the girls my [ __ ] is already
don't then the boys you're on there just
hold each other's feet you guys we're
doing it together
make sure to spread your butt like if we
spread the butt but you know so the
butthole could get a little bit
maybe you could have your own four
corners and not look at each other yeah
after you jack off together
to looking over yeah you got to check
out first bro yeah
it'd be weird if you didn't see you
don't get turned on should you have a ca
you could still get it
i don't know a little bit of a chub so
you get a nice even tan though
yeah oh treasure you do have half a half
yeah yeah it's like
right here is hella white right and in
the [ __ ] thigh
and then my dick is dark as [ __ ] and
then it goes back to dark right here
so it's such a weird yeah neopolitan ice
cream we gotta start bringing back
speedos in or something
yeah yeah some people never let them go
i know it's a nice even tan on the thigh
you don't want to guess the talon
it's very european very european would
you ever do a nude beach
uh i don't know i can't
i can't read i can't gauge where you're
at what do you think
with the homies to not wear clothes and
feel free as [ __ ]
that's the appeal that's true
yeah i'm talking about naked yeah yeah
i'll do some naked jiu-jitsu is that
what you're asking no oh nude beach
would you go to nude beach with their
wife uh
honestly probably not you don't want to
see her naked
well we haven't done it yet we haven't
seen we haven't seen each other naked
yet good you have to save yourself oh
neither have bart and i
yeah well it's just like it's kind of a
weird pretense but it's just our own
rules
yeah this is what we do yeah we do sexy
time one of us goes in the closet and we
just like
just tell her she goes oh yeah and he
goes yeah and you guys just make noises
oh you have that glory hole huh yeah
glory holes is key bro that's pretty hot
yeah yeah have you guys installed you
have a hole in a in the closet you know
it's really close but crotchless stuff
where did you guys install your glue
hole in your new house
tiger's room where it's appropriate yeah
yeah tech has put his hand through it
all the time
hey bro you put a glory all in your
kid's room i know i was just trying to
be uncomfortable
he's putting his own like round blocks
inside
[Laughter]
i don't understand the appeal but um
[ __ ] together sure not be judged should
we grab our toes and do it or what
should we we're all here in the line
like dude
man was right i know this
it does feel good you sold it though jio
sold it thanks she sold
it i mean she brought in the warm cookie
from costco i guess that's what it is
yeah it does feel good to swim
completely naked versus having like
oh yeah but i'm afraid that the sharks
gonna come and bite the worm on me
and don't jump up the water bruh if this
dude's near you he's gonna be [ __ ]
in the water and it's gonna attract all
the sharks
naked and you threw up again oh man oh
bro your worm is gone bruh
done i'm gonna get barracuda bites on my
dick yeah and then once it
once you tan it it's gone and you're
like all this work that you did for your
dick and balls
no you have penis transplants now oh
that's true they just have you could use
it on your color if you want it oh
[ __ ] you're right i want mine
what i want mine i don't want a
transplant i'd rather keep it safe
but if you could get a transplant what
kind of dick would you get
like you want an american one you want a
four-inch a way bigger one
yeah i want the same size but i want it
to come fast
oh like really fast you went extra
nervous like i want
yeah i want um junior high there talk
about your lover you don't give up
[ __ ] but i would like to think that she
was comfortable
with my size no but you said you want to
come fast
oh i want to come fast and frequently
like okay imagine
imagine you had that puberty dick
multiple orgasms you can just keep going
yeah but you have
a female partner instead of your own
hand
yeah because guys guys be jacking up
can't imagine wishing wishing that one
day we could get laid
and then you finally start doing it but
it's like man
but i wanted it when i was the most like
ready for it
true like by the time we actually have
uh like
access to [ __ ] yeah it's like past the
prime
essentials you're over trained yeah
maybe that was the test from god and all
you [ __ ] failed like you were
supposed to just slow it down and not
[ __ ] yeah but once you discover jacking
off it's
you're not supposed to come on man it's
a crack pipe remember the bible warned
you guys
because how do you know you're ready
how how what you got yeah what's the
point of you not knowing you know but
your hands doing all the work and not
your hips
so there's no practice how's the
practice that means you just got weak
no some of us use our hips i keep my
hand in place
he's like this no that's still your head
keep keeping it in place and you move
your head yeah so you don't see you yeah
you like this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
give it to a good
slap your own hand yeah you [ __ ] just
so [ __ ] bad
oh my god bad bad can you imagine you
walk into your son's room you hear like
him talking to someone like who is that
and you see that
are his hips his hips are moving then
i'd be like good job you're lying that's
a dope stroke
his hands that's why
what are you doing not your hands
today's video is brought to you by
upstart and i'm so excited because you
know i've been waiting to buy
a brand new car ooh i want a car too
what are you gonna get since 2019 well
i'm gonna i'm
in between either a ram truck or a
silverado truck and i've been waiting
for our house escrow stuff to be over
because you don't want to
mess with your credit score when you're
trying to get into a 30-year loan with
the house
right that's over i'm scot-free i talked
to my loan officer with it i'm good so
now i can look into
getting a car but now with getting a car
i still need another loan
the interest rates are coming up with
like the financing and the banks and
stuff
so what i like about upstart is now i
don't just have that one option you know
when you go to the car dealership and
you're trying to negotiate a price and
they go
this is interest rate you get based off
just your credit score and you're like
oh [ __ ]
and you don't really have time to like
well let me go back to like wells fargo
and see if they can give me an audio
look at this five minutes boom up start
food this is what they're about to offer
me can you beat it because they always
hit you with
if you leave right now this deal might
not be here anymore and you're like
[ __ ] but if you have upstart
and it's only gonna take five minutes
you could put your credit score
your credit score your income all the
other stuff in your
application like your education and now
you actually have something that's
competitive and you can show them
immediately up to fifty thousand dollars
in the next
business day that's a call right there
fifty thousand dollars oh yeah that's a
good one so it's very very helpful so
i'm really excited that upstart exists
because now i feel like i get to go into
these negotiations
with a little bit of backup and if
you're looking for a backup go to
upstart.com
off the record to see if you can lower
your credit card interest rates any
other loan interest rates that you're
looking into or consolidating debt
they do all of that stuff go to
upstart.com
off the record and your actual loan
amount will be based off your income
credit score and the information you put
on the application only takes five
minutes go to upstart.com off the record
how old were you when you started
jacking off the first i'm not even
imagining my son
the first time like like a normal human
being
i think like uh maybe 13 or 14
but i've been tree humping since i was
the secretary
i was like dry humping [ __ ] not knowing
that i was like masturbating since i was
like
five or six let's talk about [ __ ] i
didn't know what it was i just
realized like it felt good violence
being at school
do you think all the teachers know i
didn't have to know it big big no bruh
teacher april oh no
when you work with a lot of kids you
just see some [ __ ] that kids do we were
like oh they're like
they're learning [ __ ] they're about
their bodies yeah yeah that's why they
love we love the jungle gym whether
whether it's like
obviously that's a lot more rare i've
never really seen like kids being like
sexually
i've never seen that but like you just
see kids like figuring [ __ ] out as they
go on and you're like oh man like that's
crazy like they're figuring
stuff out as kids they're like
chimpanzees yeah
yeah little they're testing boundaries
constantly they're just [ __ ]
they're dry humping all the time bro you
know amen you know
that's that's what you did i remember
the jungle like
like not the jungle gym the [ __ ] what
are you yeah monkey bars
right we would play the monkey bar
battle and then guys would scissor each
other
and they would stay extra long rubbing
and scissoring
is that what was happening now there was
one guy that we didn't all like because
he would rub his
nuts on your [ __ ] belly when he got
his legs around you
he would get you he starts rubbing
himself and i'm like
you got me already let me go
like he was low-key kind of molesting us
dude
[Laughter]
where his eyes rolling nah he would grab
you and he starts [ __ ] humping and
[ __ ] and then i was like man that's why
i don't like to [ __ ] play with you
you know i go you already got me
i'm like let go already hey did any of
you guys play that game
yeah did you yeah you meet in the middle
right and then you fight
and you try to grab them like you try to
lock them with your legs
and when you get them the other person
lets go and then you like
you let them know like chicken yeah yeah
when you said scissoring all i could
picture is just two kids scissors and i
was like wait what
no there are guys who who didn't play it
right they would scissor each other for
like ever
yeah and i'm just like come on man
you're taking so long
go back like this i don't know how to
play it right
oh [ __ ] whoops
that's not working yeah i play it a
different way
[Music]
watch mark 1's vlog to see us play this
weekend
yeah i swear though looking back they're
like so like one one of our old friends
came out gay and stuff
and then like it makes sense right
because when you're a kid you don't know
gay or any of these things
but he always wanted to be the sister or
the wife
he always wanted to be that role and
then he always liked to kiss
uh like whoever's playing the husband
goodbye
wouldn't you want to be the dog dog was
funny but bar i think that was bart
okay i always like the brother though
you wanna you wanna sniff buds
no cause like no one ever wants to be
the pet yeah but then if you're the pet
i can crawl into the girl like if i have
a crush on a girl you're crawling into
her lap
pervert and now she gets to pet me the
whole time that's time i'm on the dog
you came home from more good times yeah
that's good and i'm like i don't like
hair
all right we're not playing though right
not playing how old were you when you
did that
probably like first grade second grade
oh that's not bad bro but he knew what
he was doing
yeah like the husband would go off to
work i'm like oh he's got to keep you
company
let me call that lap girl the dog hit me
pet
but i think back then it's probably just
you just wanted to have like physical
touch with
with another girl or something right
yeah when i was like six or seven i
don't know what's happening
i just wanted to be cool dudes would do
dude because i remember going like
man that's weird you're not a girl but
you always want to be the
mom and then like they'll be like okay
buy honey i made you lunch and then they
would kiss
like with the husband
that's tight yeah and we would just play
with it because when you're
like i think kids are the best actors
because when you like set a rule you
[ __ ] commit yeah yeah brother
you know like this is what i wanted to
do like you know that is true kids
commit
they you go hardcore they go method bro
they go method acting
this is my wife [ __ ] don't talk [ __ ]
about my wife
it's pretty funny because like when i uh
tuck tycho away for a bed when i
uh kiss him good night i'm trying to
kiss him on the cheek but he wants to
kiss on the lips
so as i'm going i'm trying to avoid the
cheek and he's like
oh that's so cute
i kiss him on the lips oh yeah no
you're not doing it right
no it was tom brady remember when he
went viral because he made his
awesome give him a kiss on the lips oh
why is that viral yeah that's crazy this
was i forgot how many years ago it was a
few years ago before the
uh super bowl it just went viral because
a
uh team was following him just recording
his daily life to see
like how he was prepping for the super
bowl and there was a part where he was
on a
massage table and he was facing uh face
side up
and his son came to visit him said hi he
was on his way out and he's okay give
dad a kiss and he gives uh
him a really kiss peck on the lips and
he's like
longer
like when you watch it it might be a
little weird if you're not used to like
physical affection from your family
that's hilarious so many people were so
weirded out that it was like a dad and a
son
that they're like oh he's perverted tom
brady's uh like
why do they have to sexually why are you
sexualizing this he's just asking for
like hey give me a kiss before you leave
it's like hey longer hug do you know
what i mean
oh that was actually for a longer kiss
yeah it wasn't long ago
but like the way he was asking it is
similar to like grab my ass a little bit
like hey give me a real hug you know
what i mean like don't give me one of
these
like lame ones and then run out the door
yeah i actually say goodbye to me i mean
that does weird my brain out but i could
see like i mean if it's just how their
culture is within the family it's like
oh
yeah more power to you too everyone's
like yo this fool's gay that's what
everyone's saying in the comments and
[ __ ] you know it's like protective son
it's like [ __ ] yeah yeah he's a
pedophile is his son
he's 27
[Laughter]
like first grade second grade something
i thought he was like 28 and that would
have been funnier
it's tom brady though bro longer open
your mouth
yeah yeah hold me a little bit yeah pull
my hair come on
me in the face for the super bowl
now that is probably a little odd to see
because you don't really see that that
often right
we see like a a dad kiss or something
but even for me it's kind of weird
because my dad never kissed me on the
lips yeah
but then i don't so it's it feels weird
but i don't know why it's weird
so if i don't know why then i don't want
to add like my own stigma to it so when
he want
wanted to kiss me on the lips i'm like
oh [ __ ] it let's do it bro i told my dad
i loved him once
like recently and he goes like all right
see you later
[Laughter]
he was all weird and [ __ ] like yo and it
was like it was one of the first times i
was like oh yeah i love you you know
like that
and he's like okay cool he's like
oh [ __ ] he's probably just like tripping
outward he's
these millennials are so gay my old son
loved him he told them in
english my dad speaks english like
english you know he speaks mandarin but
he sounds like
people when they when i hear him talk on
the phone they think he's a black dude
or a white guy
and then every time they meet him
they're like oh okay oh yeah because he
grew up in the states you grew up
oh well he was like what like like ten
so it's like perfecting came from taiwan
yeah yeah so he still doesn't say it he
doesn't have an accent
he weird he lives in taiwan right now oh
yeah he's he's
he talks like this his name is john dunn
he sounds like that john
john dunn is a very non-asian name it is
john dunn he's a very strong name too
yeah it sounds very um
too bad he's a [ __ ] bro you're that
you're a [ __ ] dog
that's my life that's what i like to
hear you're a [ __ ] i love [ __ ]
i'll beat your ass bro that's my son
now i'm coming for you pharrell i'm
gonna beat your [ __ ] ass dude he
probably tells all his friends did you
know my son
kicked my ass i feel like that was the
rite of passage for a lot of families
where it's like
when you beat your dad down that's when
you know
you became a man is that okay yeah
that's a for sure thing yeah it is yeah
yeah yeah catch these hands
i don't know if you guys are [ __ ]
with me no seriously seriously like
there is a i do remember distinctly
feeling like oh yeah like
that beat him up basketball for real and
then you know like if you're wrestling
or some [ __ ] and he quits first and i'm
like
my brother you're a [ __ ]
my brother had a fist fight with my dad
and i was like man i can't wait today
to that day comes for me too
it's not my culture it's just my shitty
family did you ever fight him
no he left before i had the chance hey
wait till you see him though wait till
you see if it's on site
at all maybe that's why he left i know
he's like he's like
holy [ __ ] his brother's small but his
little brother's bigger
you see how above joe is right now he's
eating really clean you know he's like
i get my ass beat twice all right that
was gonna come in with a [ __ ] injury
like yeah i'm back in your life dude
he's not even [ __ ] up he's still gonna
[ __ ] him up though right
i'm gonna kick that cane off
[Music]
do
you